big news from the president's hometown
of new york city well his former
hometown where a man named frank james
has been apprehended after now allegedly
firing over 30 rounds into a crowded
subway in brooklyn new york shooting 10
commuters now tonight the perpetrators
twisted motives and ideology are coming
into focus and what are a series of
deranged videos filled with violent
rhetoric posted on youtube well james
was railing against white people asian
americans jewish americans hispanic
americans and the united states of
america even trash joe biden's supreme
court nominee judge jackson because she
quote married a white man james also
filmed himself on the streets of new
york screaming racial racial slurs at
asians and hispanics as they walked by
telling them they shouldn't exist and
according to social media he was also a
big supporter of screwy louis farrakhan
lois farrakhan of the nation of islam
naturally this story will be swept under
the rug by the media mob a guest frank
james probably won't fit their political
narrative in fact one disappointed
former mms dnc host tweeted quote police
say the suspect is a male black damn
damn damn how about we just get the bad
guy and we protect the good guys all
people
anyway coming up we'll get president
trump's reaction to this attack the
deteriorating conditions in america's
major cities law and order safety
security can't pursue happiness without
it first more bad news from biden's
disastrous economy thought it was bad
yesterday well we can now report brand
new numbers out today wholesale prices
have surged by a whopping 11.2 percent
in march
this is the highest increase year over
year
ever in history when donald trump left
office it was
1.6
and make no mistake these costs
wholesale prices they will be passed on
to you the consumer wholesale price
increases are paid by the people like us
that buy retail look at your screen
wholesale prices have been rising during
the entire biden presidency month after
month worse and worse and it's not
vladimir putin's fault just like
inflation like we showed you last night
also has been on a steep incline ever
since the day that joe biden was sworn
in just like gas prices as you can see
right there uh which is why they were
rising way before vladimir putin invaded
ukraine this is an excuse these are
three big lies told by joe biden and of
course his minions and the media mob now
keep in mind when donald trump left
office an average gallon of gasoline at
the pump was two dollars and 42 cents
inflation was only 1.4
not 8.5 and clearly biden's green new
deal climate alarmist socialist agenda
is an unmitigated disaster you don't
have to graduate from harvard or mit to
figure that out now he restricted
domestic oil and gas product production
he killed the keystone xl pipeline by
the way the premier in alberta made the
statement that had he not stopped
production it would be finished by now
and we would be importing 900 000
uh barrels of oil canadian oil every
single day we could get back to building
it and get that oil and even help out
our friends uh in western europe anyway
he spent trillions of dollars on
handouts the economy is now suffering in
every way imaginable and about to get
worse but today
as we predicted right here on this show
monday we told you on monday that the
numbers are coming out tuesday and
wednesday we told you that that jenn
saki joe biden and company would be full
of excuses starting with blame vladimir
take a look
so does the president then acknowledge
any responsibility for the inflation
that we're seeing now based on the
decisions that he's made when he came
into office
well i would say as the president has
talked about quite a bit there are a
range of factors including uh the
pandemic the impact on the supply chains
and our effort and what we've tried to
do from the beginning is take steps to
address that given energy is such an a
significant driver of this data an
increase in energy prices over the last
month plus since the invasion of ukraine
that's factual that's based on data that
we have seen out there so our effort and
our focus has been to try to address it
and take mitigation measures when we can
all right circle back ginsake you can
see there by the way well should be
great on msdnc because they never tell
the truth anyway she's not fooling
anybody look at this quinnipiac poll out
today a plurality of americans think
biden is the most responsible for the
spike in gas prices and of course the
record high inflation
now more new numbers today from
quinnipiac have found that their polling
is showing joe biden's approval rating
at its lowest point ever
33
only 26
of independents approve of joe biden now
today five different polls have biden
underwater by double digits americans
are not happy biden's religious climate
alarmist uh policies have been a
nightmare but instead of of going to the
simple answer changing course admitting
failure the biden administration just
doubles down on what's not working and
today biden's treasury secretary vowed
to redouble her efforts to decarbonize
our economy no we should be drilling we
should be fracking and we should be
extracting coal that is the lifeblood of
the world's economy but why go for the
obvious take a look
the recent ipcc reports confirm
that our window of opportunity to leave
our planet worthy of our children and
our grandchildren
is even closer to being permanently shut
we must redouble our efforts to
decarbonize our economies
recognizing that countries will use a
range of tools
including carbon pricing
regulation and subsidies
to achieve needed emission reductions
yeah they decarbonize and then we become
more dependent on let's see russia iran
opec venezuela not a good uh plan for
national security reasons in other words
even less domestic production of the
lifeblood of our economy which is oil
gas etc and costs that will continue to
rise every single uh week every single
month for every single american what's
the definition of insanity isn't that
doing the same dumb thing over and over
again and expecting a different result
because that's what they're doing they
don't care if you suffer they don't care
if you have trouble paying your bills
they don't care if your life gets worse
they don't care about the high cost of a
gallon of gasoline they just lecture you
on driving less and getting electric
cars that most people can't afford their
religious climate alarmist cult that's
the only thing that matters your
sacrifice is what a small price to pay
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else